[Aplausos]
[Música]
Venezuela es el país de la crisis
económica eterna y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando mucho pues vaya novedad nos
vienes a contar Fonseca Sí cierto en
este canal le hemos dedicado muchísimos
vídeos a este país latinoamericano y
desde luego se puede decir que sus
crisis política económica y humanitaria
están más que documentadas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en los últimos años por ejemplo nos
hemos centrado en el continuo tira y
afloja entre el chavismo y la oposición
cuando la lideraba Juan guaidó también
en el narco estado dirigido por diosdado
cabello y en el colapso económico
permanente en el que vive sumido este
país pero hoy vamos a hablaros de algo
nuevo y totalmente diferente de otra de
las graves consecuencias de la
Revolución bolivariana vamos a hablaros
del ecocidio que se está produciendo en
Venezuela Y sí habéis oído bien ecocidio
ojo Esto no es porque lo digamos
Nosotros ni ningún sicario del
imperialismo Es que así lo llama el
mismísimo presidente Nicolás Maduro
atentos todos los parques nacionales del
Estado Bolívar y todas las regiones
Milena mineras a liberarlas de mafias
cocidas porque es un ecocidio lo que se
está cometiendo allí es un ecocidio
habéis oído bien la minería ilegal está
provocando graves daños en la amazonía
que pertenece al territorio de Venezuela
pero esperad un momento por qué esta
crisis que vive el país también está
causando problemas a la petrolera
estatal pedevesa con graves
consecuencias para el medio ambiente Así
que la pregunta que hoy nos hacemos Es
que está pasando con pedevesa quién está
detrás de la minería ilegal en Venezuela
y otra cuestión también más importante
Qué consecuencias está teniendo todo
esto para las enormes riquezas naturales
de Venezuela hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
[Música]
la gran Venezuela
el pasado mes de diciembre se cumplieron
100 años del primer gran descubrimiento
de petróleo en Venezuela en un principio
la producción era realizada por empresas
extranjeras la ley de hidrocarburos del
año 1943 ya les obligó a entregar el 50%
de sus ganancias al Estado venezolano el
oro negro trajo mucha riqueza este país
y por aquel entonces Venezuela era el
tercer mayor productor mundial de zumo
de dinosaurio solo por detrás de la
unión soviética y de los Estados Unidos
pero también hizo la economía venezolana
muy dependiente del precio del petróleo
la caída constante del precio del crudo
empujó a Venezuela a unirse a varios
países de oriente medio para fundar la
Organización de Países exportadores de
petróleo en 1960
la posición de la OPEP en la crisis del
petróleo de 1973 cuadriplicó los precios
del crudo Venezuela aprovechó este auge
para registrar el pib Per cápita más
alto de América Latina Durante los años
70 el entonces presidente Carlos Andrés
Pérez anunció triunfalmente la llegada
de la gran Venezuela que utilizaría la
riqueza del petróleo para desarrollar
aún más la nación uno de los primeros
pasos fue disminuir la dependencia de
las operaciones de compañías petroleras
extranjeras nacionalizando la industria
a través de la creación de pedevesa en
[Música]
la nacionalización de la industria
petrolera tuvo unos dañas controlados
iban en Venezuela ya se habían llegado a
producir 3,5 millones de barriles de
petróleo diarios pedevesa tuvo un éxito
notable alcanzando una producción de 2,3
millones de barriles diarios durante sus
primeros cuatro años de operaciones
Incluso a finales de los años 90 Cuando
la corrupción ya acampaba sus anchas por
la política venezolana pedevesa se
aproximó a niveles récord de producción
con casi 3,3 millones de barriles de
petróleo al día sin embargo mis queridos
amigos de visualpolitik esta Bonanza no
se aprovechó como es debido
el fracaso de Venezuela para frenar la
corrupción y reinvertir los ingresos del
petróleo en una economía más
diversificada sentó las bases para la
caída de la economía venezolana y ya
tenía bastantes problemas el país y su
industria petrolera cuando en 1999 llegó
al poder el comandante Hugo Chávez
trajo una nueva forma de hacer política
el chavismo un estilo autoritario y
populista que tenía partidarios pero
también muchos detractores Pero sigo
siendo
[Música]
en 2002 se convocó una huelga nacional
para reclamar elecciones y de hecho tuvo
un gran seguimiento en pedevesa llegaron
a reducir la producción de petróleo de
los 3 millones diarios a 50.000 barriles
sabes contraatacó despidiendo a 18.000
empleados de pedevesa casi la mitad del
personal total de esta empresa lo
reemplazó como os podéis imaginar con
gente que no tenía ni idea del sector
petrolero pero que eso sí eran leales al
régimen Y sí habéis oído bien Así es
como ha funcionado la política de
recursos humanos de pedevesa desde
entonces atentos maduro des a primo de
Chávez presidente de la filial de
pedevesa en Estados Unidos para que os
hagáis una idea esto es como cuando el
Barça quiso reemplazar a Messi y a Luis
Suárez con Bueno mira poned Vosotros los
nombres vale pero viene a dar lo mismo
lo importante es que los nuevos
jugadores pueden ocupar el mismo puesto
Pero obviamente no te dan los mismos
resultados Pues en pedevesa pasó
Exactamente lo mismo
nunca se recuperaron de aquella pérdida
masiva de talento Venezuela nunca más
alcanzó su objetivo de producción de 3,5
millones de barriles de petróleo al día
y el golpe definitivo al sector lo dio
Chávez en 2007 cuando ordenó la
expropiación de los activos de exxon
Mobile y konoko Philips estas empresas
habían sido contratadas para desarrollar
la faja del Orinoco que contiene
reservas de crudo extrapesado esta
reserva son muy grandes pero son muy
difíciles de procesar y por eso
necesitan tecnología especial la
explotación a las petroleras
estadounidenses provocó una fuga de
capital extranjero lo que dejó a
Venezuela incapaz de acceder
eficientemente a gran parte de sus
reservas de crudo pesado y diréis en qué
se tradujo todo esto os lo podría contar
pero casi mejor que lo veáis por
vosotros mismos
la producción de petróleo de Venezuela
se mantuvo en torno a los 3 millones de
barriles diarios durante prácticamente
una década pero como ya recordaréis en
el año 2014 el precio del crudo en el
mercado internacional cayó en picado y
al régimen chavista le empezaron a
faltar los dólares necesarios para
mantener en buenas condiciones de
operación sus yacimientos petrolíferos
el resultado Pues que hoy las
instalaciones de pedevesa se caen a
pedazos su soleoductos están
deteriorados después de estar años y
años operando sin siquiera ser revisados
todo se ha quedado anticuado el declive
de la petrolera estatal Es evidente pero
debes ha caído al fondo de un pozo del
que le va a costar salir muchísimo y hay
dos víctimas que están pagando las
consecuencias la primera víctima es muy
evidente el medio ambiente venezolano
[Música]
entre 2010 y 2016 p debes se informó de
que se habían producido
46.000 derrames de petróleo en sus
operaciones una media de 18 al día desde
entonces se niegan a facilitar datos así
pero no hay nada que indique que la
situación haya mejorado los trabajadores
aseguran que los incendios y las
explosiones en las refinerías son
relativamente comunes al igual que las
tuberías rotas y los derrames y la
petrolera estatal atraviesa por una
situación aún más comprometida desde que
Estados Unidos aplicó sanciones al
petróleo de pedevesa como castigo al
chavismo tras el reconocimiento de Juan
guaidó como presidente
la propia pedevesa estima que
necesitaría invertir unos 8.000 millones
de dólares para actualizar su
infraestructura de oleoductos y volver a
alcanzar su récord de producción de hace
25 años Mientras tanto continúan los
derrames derrochando el zumo de
dinosaurio y contaminando las aguas
costeras y fluviales por lo tanto sucede
con de gas natural en los pozos de
petróleo un sector energético eficiente
intentaría extraer este gas para
aprovecharlo y poderlo vender verdad
pero claro eso requeriría tener una
infraestructura adecuada unos gasoductos
en condiciones etcétera Pues bien como
Venezuela no tiene nada de eso p de
besas está dedicando a quemarlo habéis
oído bien obviamente lo hacen por
motivos de seguridad pero esto es un
problemón medioambiental porque aumenta
las emisiones de CO2 y de gas metano y
diréis que están haciendo para
solucionarlo Pues más bien nada porque
en pdvsa están ocupados con otras cosas
exclusiva intermediarios han dejado a la
venezolana pedevesa con 21.200 millones
de dólares en facturas impagadas
para que os hagáis una idea algunas
estimaciones cifran el saqueo de
pedevesa en la friolera de 100 mil
millones de dólares Así que
efectivamente la segunda víctima de la
mala gestión de la petrolera estatal es
la propia economía venezolana hace 10
años las exportaciones de petróleo
suponían el 95% del total del país este
porcentaje llegó al 65% Y ante el
declive de pedevesa y la caída de los
precios del crudo maduro buscó una
alternativa un plan para reactivar el
sector minero de Venezuela queréis saber
de qué estamos hablando Pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
el arco minero del Orinoco
el sector minero nunca tuvo gran
importancia para Venezuela maduro hizo
que esto cambiara en 2016 y para ello
decretó la creación del Arco minero del
Orinoco se trata de un territorio en el
sur de Venezuela con forma de media luna
y del tamaño de Cuba Su objetivo era
atraer inversiones para la extracción de
oro hierro cobalto bauxita tantalita
diamantes y otros minerales obviamente
la anula seguridad jurídica que ofrece
Venezuela ahuyentó a los posibles socios
y todo ha resultado ser una sombra del
Gran proyecto anunciado a bombo y
platillo por Maduro actualmente la mayor
parte de los recursos minerales están
siendo explotados por mafias ilegales
que actúan con impunidad Con cuánta
impunidad pues la suficiente como para
disponer de esto para sacar el oro en el
país la minería ilegal montó sus bases
aéreas en la selva esta investigación
Indicó que Los contrabandistas utilizan
al menos 42 pistas de aterrizaje
clandestinas también se cree que el 91%
del Oro de Venezuela se produce de forma
ilegal y que posteriormente se
transporta hacia los países vecinos por
este motivo no hay cifras creíbles de
cuánto oro exactamente se produce en
Venezuela los planes de maduro eran
producir alrededor de 80 toneladas de
oro anuales para 2025 sin embargo en
realidad la producción probablemente ya
está muy cerca de ese número pero claro
el problema es que la mayoría de las
minas de las rutas comerciales están
controladas por bandas criminales
una vez más podéis haceros la idea de
toda la enorme riqueza que pierde el
estado venezolano al no tener un control
fiscal sobre estos recursos pero
esperado un momento porque hay cosas aún
peores la minería ilegal utiliza
mercurio para extraer el oro del mineral
lo que está teniendo unas consecuencias
letales y mucho ojo porque lo hacen con
la plena convivencia del régimen es un
negocio también
de el régimen
es la venta del mercurio para hacer
minería ilegal Y entonces este mercurio
pues está quedando en los ríos y está
envenenando a no solo los mineros pero a
los pueblos indígenas que viven en los
alrededores de estas Minas
ese o ese Orinoco estima que hasta el
70% del curso del Río caroni el segundo
más grande de Venezuela con casi 1000
kilómetros de largo está en riesgo de
contaminación con mercurio
los pemones que es el principal grupo
indígena de la zona presentan niveles de
mercurio muy superiores a los
considerados seguros por la OMS y el
medio ambiente es de nuevo una víctima
de lo que pasa en Venezuela de hecho la
minería hacia lo abierto que se practica
es muy agresiva con el territorio en los
últimos 20 años la deforestación alcanzó
unos 3.800 kilómetros cuadrados de la
amazonía venezolana el 1% del total y la
tendencia va a más ante la difícil
situación por la que atraviesan los
[Música]
los salarios se han derrumbado en la
Venezuela de maduro muchos trabajadores
ganan menos de 10 dólares
estadounidenses al mes Así que la
minería ilegal Se ha vuelto muy
atractiva dada la ausencia total de
alternativas decenas de miles de
personas en su mayoría hombres se han
mudado para probar suerte en este
trabajo
la minería ilegal también se ha
convertido en la única vía de
subsistencia para muchos indígenas ante
el desplome del turismo
Y por supuesto estos mineros no tienen
salarios se quedan el 40% del Oro que
encuentran y el 60% es para el
propietario de la mina los mineros
pueden cambiarlo por efectivo en los
campamentos pero a un precio muy
reducido por desgracia Este no es el
único abuso que sufren estos
trabajadores la ONU ya constató en un
informe los constantes abusos de
Derechos Humanos que se dan en esta zona
para colmo la minería ilegal está
controlada por grupos armados como el
ejército de liberación Nacional de
Colombia y facciones disidentes de las
FARC también por grupos criminales como
el tren de aragua o el tren de guayana y
os aseguro que no se andan con rodeos
para hacerse con los recursos mineros
atentos desmantelan campamento con armas
de guerra del tren de guayana en Bolívar
por supuesto todas estas mafias operan
con el visto bueno de los peces gordos
del régimen bolivariano las autoridades
regionales Y por supuesto los oficiales
del ejército bolivariano todos ellos han
recibido sobornos de los grupos
criminales en una zona donde el estado
ya ha perdido el control total de la
situación las mafias campan a sus anchas
Mirad el mapa del Parque Nacional de
canaima según sos Orinoco hay hasta 27
áreas mineras en el borde del parque
muchas en el río caroni y otras 32 en su
interior la situación es tan preocupante
como triste
Venezuela es un estado que fue pionero
en Latinoamérica en la protección de
espacios naturales y hoy es incapaz de
proteger su medio ambiente más preciado
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
pero hay alguna forma de contrarrestar
este
ecocidio venezolano Pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
susto o muerte
poco se puede hacer desde fuera de
Venezuela para frenar el ecocidio que
está teniendo lugar Dentro de este país
una de las fórmulas que más adeptos
tiene es la de clasificar el oro
extraído de Venezuela como oro de
conflicto o al igual que se dice con el
tráfico de diamantes como oro de sangre
desde luego no faltan motivos para
hacerlo la minería ilegal de Venezuela
está generando una importante ola de
violencia en las pugnas por su control
en el sur del país está enriqueciendo a
grupos criminales y también está
llenando los bolsillos de sus
gobernantes corruptos por todos estos
motivos Estados Unidos ya sancionó el
sector aurífero venezolano Hace 4 años
sin embargo mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik hay dudas de la
efectividad de este tipo de medidas es
improbable que las sanciones y las
prohibiciones detengan el comercio del
Oro de sangre venezolano y posiblemente
incluso favorezcan que su mercado
continúe aún más en manos criminales por
todos es sabido que hay grandes
cantidades de oro de sangre que escapa
de Venezuela por las fronteras con sus
países vecinos Allí se suman al
inventario de exportadores autorizados
que posteriormente envían el oro a la
refinerías más importantes del mundo esa
es la realidad sabiéndolo no esta
refinerías están comprando oro de sangre
y El caso es que por una u otra vía el
rastro del Oro venezolano Llega hasta
los lugares más insospechados Irán
contra bandera oro venezolano para
financiar a hetbolá
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
que elección más difícil verdad si
sancionas el oro venezolano acabas
financiando organizaciones terroristas y
si no lo sancionas estás dando oxígeno
al chavismo susto o muerte por una
situación similar atravesado ya el
petróleo de Venezuela como os contábamos
antes Estados Unidos sancionó el
petróleo de pedevesa a raíz de la crisis
presidencial de 2019 lo que nadie se
podía haber venir Es que años más tarde
Estados Unidos fuera el primer
interesado en suavizar posturas ante el
régimen de maduro y diréis por qué Pues
creo que ya os podéis imaginar el motivo
la Guerra de Ucrania de repente
Washington está interesado en ese crudo
extrapesado de Venezuela para suplir el
crucero extra pesado que antes traían de
Rusia Mirad lo que se anunció en
noviembre
Chevron reanudará la producción de
petróleo en Venezuela mientras Estados
Unidos alivia las sanciones
[Música]
actualmente Estados Unidos está
importando 100.000 barriles diarios de
petróleo venezolano a cambio de que
Washington haya autorizado estas
importaciones el chavismo ha reanudado
las conversaciones que se celebran en
México con su oposición además se han
producido avances en el terreno político
y desde Caracas ya están pidiendo el fin
de todas las sanciones impuestas por los
Estados Unidos ya veremos Cómo
evoluciona este asunto pero desde luego
no se puede decir lo contrario estas son
buenas noticias para Nicolás Maduro de
hecho el Palacio de Miraflores podría
ser una fiesta de no ser por el enésimo
escandalazo que asola estos días a
pedevesa un escándalo del que ya os
hemos hablado aquí hace muy poco tiempo
en visualpolitik en un vídeo que por
cierto os dejo aquí en la descripción
antes veíamos el titular una auditoría
ha descubierto que la petrolera estatal
acumula 21.200 millones de dólares en
facturas pendientes de cobro Durante los
últimos tres años en otras palabras que
pedevesa aún no ha cobrado el 84% de sus
exportaciones de crudo desde 2020 de
hecho ya se cifra en 3.600 millones de
dólares la suma que posiblemente nunca
se cobre por tratarse de operaciones
intermediarios poco fiables el
presidente de pedevesa en este periodo
ha sido Asdrúbal Chávez el primo del
expresidente que fue ascendido por
Maduro de forma meteórica fue cesado por
el presidente venezolano el pasado 6 de
enero pero esperad un momento porque las
cabezas siguen rodando ministro de
petróleo de Venezuela renuncia en medio
de investigación de corrupción de
pedevesa desde luego este 2023 está
siendo muy Movidito para pedevesa la
nueva gerencia se está dedicando a
revisar los contratos de la petrolera y
endurecer las condiciones de prepago
para su crudo todo esto ha provocado que
a pesar de que el país esté consiguiendo
incrementar su producción de oro negro
las exportaciones se hayan disminuido ya
que las embarcaciones están siendo
retenidas en los puertos venezolanos sin
poder zarpar hasta que se confirme el
dichoso pago del zumo de dinosaurios
Qué hacen las inversiones precisas la
llegada de efectivo a pedevesa es la
única forma de que el incremento de
producción de crudo no venga acompañada
de más derrames del mismo modo mayores
exportaciones podrían mejorar la
situación de la economía venezolana y
reducir la importancia del sector minero
podría ser por tanto un incentivo para
combatir la minería ilegal y ofrecer
alternativas como proyectos agrícolas o
turísticos a muchos venezolanos que
actualmente ven en la minería su única
forma de ganarse la vida
sin embargo seamos honestos una buena
gestión de pedevesa parece imposible al
menos mientras continúe el chavismo y a
la vez un escenario sin el régimen de
maduro al frente no parece muy realista
actualmente por tanto el chavismo vive
en una crisis permanente Pero vive y
ahora la pregunta es para vosotros hace
bien Estados Unidos en volver a importar
petróleo de Venezuela o creéis que Joe
biden está dando oxígeno al régimen
corrupto de Nicolás maduro y está
actuando contra los intereses de la
oposición venezolana podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]